nous avions ce qui s'appelait à l'époque
le culturisme les américains nous l'ont
importé voici qu'il nous revient sous la
forme et le titre de bodybuilding il
paraît qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde s'y
met à commencer par les dames
alors voici sur fond de musique disco ce
fameux bodybuilding le disco ce n'est
pas par hasard il paraît également que
cela donne un petit peu des ailes aux
participants et aux pratiquants
m
oui
un simple
ouais ouais
là
est ce qui peut pousser une femme à
faire du bodybuilding
la priorité est le bien-être et les
femmes recherchent l'effort physique et
on en verra plus en plus on est à deux
pas des délits ou même souhaité être
muscu rahoui également et vous
considérer ça comme un sport ah oui à
part entière vos débuts vous c'est avant
tout un sport qui permet d'être bien
dans sa peau selon ceux et celles qui le
pratiquent les effets se font sentir dès
les premières séances
on respire mieux on dort mieux mais en
ce qui concerne la ligne les résultats
ne sont pas toujours à la hauteur des
espoirs
si l'on veut vraiment perdre du poids
grâce au culturisme
mieux vaut y associer une alimentation
équilibrée voire même un vrai génie
d'ailleurs l'équipe du club à une
formule qui résume tout si vous voulez
mincir le bodybuilding contribuera à 30%
mais l'alimentation à 70 pour simple la
musculation n'est donc pas la recette
miracle annoncé par certains d'autres
viennent au club pour développer leur
masse musculaire
chaque appareil privilégier une scierie
de muscler biceps et pectoraux ou encore
les muscles du ventre mais les
fanatiques de la gonflette se recrutent
surtout chez les hommes ont souvent la
femme n'a pas été fait
seulement pour s'occuper d'elle et fait
surtout pour d'autres tâches
leurs maisons ont vu la scion peuvent en
liberté alors elle s'occupe des son
corps la meilleure façon qui soit celle
de ce bébé de ses muses parce que s'il
ya une chose de naturel dans le corps
c'est le muscle puis de faim naturel
c'est la grèce ou la série
poma
swing